benoît martin secrétaire général unions
départementales cgt paris benoît maire
martin merci d'être avec nous par
téléphone en direct sur rt france alors
les transports un secteur clé pour
assurer la reprise économique a exprimé
hier edouard philippe notamment à paris
1 1 pour un maximum de garanties le
premier ministre a insisté
il faudra condamné un siège sur deux est
favorisée par des marquages au sol la
bonne répartition sur les caisses que
c'est réaliste selon ce qui va être
réaliste à certaines heures creuses ne
le sera plus aux heures de pointe même
s'il ya un étalement ce qu'ils demandent
également par premier ministre un
étalement des horaires mais malgré tout
je veux dire à un siège sur deux serait
valable
globalement pour la sncf pour les trains
des transports intercités ou ou tgv où
il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de personnes
debout c'est seulement etc
mais dans le métro dans le rer ou
certains trains de banlieue aux heures
chargées
il ya trois fois plus de monde debout
que deux personnes assises et donc
demandé d'être présente à sion 2 ça n'a
tout simplement aucun sens argumente où
l'on n'aura pas repris le travail le 11
mai ni le 2 juin certainement mais
malgré tout déjà aujourd'hui sur la
ligne 13 du métro par exemple celle et
les gens sont les uns sur les autres
voilà et donc il ya de gros problèmes
déjà par un temps aux gestes barrières
et à la distanciation physique qui est
demandé alors justement 70% des
transports prévue au 11 mai du coup il
faudrait plus de ram pour assurer la
sécurité de travailleurs oui plus de ram
les équipements de sécurité
d'ailleurs ce matin il y avait un
conseil économique et social centrale a
la ratp le premier point à l'ordre du
jour était justement les conditions de
retour à ce trafic plus important le 11
mai est donc là la cgt au bout d'1 50
ans à quitter la séance car la direction
ratp ne voulait pas poursuivre le débat
justement sur cette question de sécurité
de santé et voulait pouvoir passer au
point 2 de l'ordre du jour qui était un
plan de restructuration
donc on va trouver cela tout à fait
insupportable qu'il faut passer du temps
avec les organisations syndicales pour
discuter des conditions optimales de
reprise partielle le 11 mai justement
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
personnels de la ratp que vous pouvez
côtoyer ils sont rassurés moyennement
rassurer avant cette reprise du 11 mai
ils ont envie d'un peu de discours
stable et rassurant stable par exemple
il y à un mois
1 lorsque des conducteurs de bus mettez
un masque qui était une initiative
individuelle leur hiérarchie leur
demande et de l'enlever car cela faisait
peur aux gens donc là on leur demande de
mettre des masques ce qui est tout à
fait logique mais sans appeler bien
d'anticiper
voilà mais oui il va falloir du gel
hydro alcoolique il va falloir des looks
des masques lors demandé des masques
ffp2 1 ce sont des plus efficaces pour
les conducteurs pour un certain nombre
d'agents qui sont au contact des publics
ou même de leurs collègues
évidemment mais tant qu'on n'aura pas
avancé sur la kander solal la guerre
sanitaires contre la virus ça va être
très compliqué malgré tout le
gouvernement veut également le port du
masque obligatoire sous peine de
sanctions est-ce pour les voyageurs
c'est une bonne chose selon vous une
bonne chose
oui mais il ne faut pas que le port du
masque déjà il faut des masques de
qualité déjà l'iphone et une égalité
d'accès au masque est le meilleure façon
d'obtenir l'égalité ce serait là la
gratuité car aujourd'hui 1 depuis hier
ou avant-hier dans les magasins on a
trouvé des des masques mais dans les
pharmacies surtout des à des prix
prohibitifs
donc il faut le rendre accessible à tous
et puis même si on a des masques il
n'empêche que il n'ya pas que le contact
par le le nez la bouche les yeux il ya
aussi les mains un dock il faut avoir
des gants il faut avoir du nettoyage qui
se fait soit fait très régulièrement
dans les rames du métro dans les bus etc
et on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas des
moyens suffisants mis non plus sur le
nettoyage et la désinfection des rames
et des cuisses en particulier
et puis également des couvoirs des
abribus des quais de métro va falloir
des moyens considérables et protéger
également les personnels chargés du
nettoyage
merci beaucoup benoît martin d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur est étrange
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général l'union départementale cgt paris